foreign
[Music]
all right let's go
welcome back to your favorite podcast
everybody
[Music]
what's up y'all back with the woo-woos
backwards ripping with Griffin
this time I did my you know
you trying to spice it up anyways I
gotta get you some stuff I didn't get
you last week
so we got succession love that show this
new show jury duty on Amazon
and um
the NBA Playoffs we got to get to all
that so anyways thanks for being here
and welcome back as always
[Music]
anyways welcome back to River with
Griffin everybody and we live and in
full effect and we lied check out my new
little overlay you like that I hope you
like it I'm trying to get it right but
anyways as always welcome back to
riffing with Griffin
we are here you know you know how we do
river with Griffin uh please support the
show you know what I mean give us a
little support subscribe hit the
notifications so you always get it you
know we're Wednesdays you know this is
the kind of show
where I do my thing it's raw unfiltered
Sometimes some funny sometimes I'm
insightful but I'm always 100 me if
you've been here before you know what to
expect if you haven't been here before
and you're like what's going on why
isn't this guy funny or whatever you
think it is it just is what it is for
the people that I've said this to a
million times and you still want to act
up about it man shut up you know
whatever you know what I mean it is what
it is all right so thanks for coming I'm
on Twitch daily so you can catch me on
Twitch catch me on Twitch come check me
out on that and you can be a supporter
on Twitch by being a sub you could be a
supporter on patreon you could do that
which I always appreciate so thanks for
coming out and welcome back to riffin
with Griffin so here we are you know uh
we're even with Griffin uh let's see
what's going on so you know last week I
had my hat on so I've been wearing I I
have not worn my hat outside like no no
no I'm sorry to like do comedy yet so I
haven't like unveiled my hat in the
comedy war in the comedy world but I
have worn into a couple of things
but yeah so I got some comments let's
just go over some of the comments that I
got uh somebody somebody said something
Griffo who said this
tocoloshi I don't know your names are so
stupid Griffin pulls off the doors like
he gave Sinatra fashion advice thank you
oh my god
um let's see this is the big comic Griff
respectfully does Rachel like the hat if
so nothing else to discuss my man I
think it looks cool but I also realized
my opinion absolutely does not matter
all right so let's talk about that so
the other day we went to brunch in West
Hollywood with a couple of our one of
our married couple friends uh Amanda and
Miles shout out to them
so you know I had all my hat I should
have taken a picture but I had all my
hat I had this jacket on this like you
know fancy sort of uh Tommy Bahama shirt
and you know got my hat on you know and
then
Rachel's always iffy on it I don't know
if she's mocking me or if she really
likes the Hat because she'll be like
she'll be like oh no it looks good I
like do you like it you know when
somebody says that do you like it that's
when you're just like oh you don't
really like this hat huh so then she's
like no I like it it's nice you know I'm
like do you like it or not you know
she's like no wear it wear it you know
so then I go we go and then like you
know she's like whatever and then I then
we're leaving you know the restaurant
you know what I mean and then like I see
her and her friend Amanda they're like
to have a little discussion and Rachel
comes later tells me she's laughing
she's like Amanda asked did you dress
him
Rachel's like not Justin myself he did
that himself and then I was just like so
self-conscious about it you know I was
like no you know what I'm not wearing my
hat
so I'm still iffy on the hat even though
I did wear it on
I did wearing on uh the golden hour so
we'll see and we took a poll and it's
like the pope like you know it's it's
usually over it's usually like like 70
people are like oh we like the hat but
that 30 still to me is a lot you know
what I mean so it's really up to me you
know I don't know but it just was funny
all right let's get some more comments
um let's see Eric you did an amazing job
directing Matt Rife special I just saw
it wow Enrique escato yeah Matt's really
blowing up uh you know what I mean so
trying to get my directing career and
thanks to him you know what I mean I've
known Matt since he was like 14. I'm
gonna get him on the podcast again now
that he's super famous
Stephen Beck if you like the Hat I like
the Hat you look great when you feel
great exactly so she so Rachel and her
friends you know her friend cut into my
confidence so I got to get it back so
I'm just gonna wear my hat hats for
fashion are weird
J's whatever crazy I don't know what
your stupid name
here's the same stupid joke by Matt
Austin love you and soul oh you look
like the soul guy I'm so funny shut up
uh uh so
add e l king said Sons haters huh Griff
haters go sons all right so there's a
Suns fan right there uh let's see what
else we got here
uh
uh let's see
I don't know what's going on here uh
just a lot of people David
Lopez Jr
love Eric this podcast so raw just
awesome thank you
um what else you know anyways a lot of
great comments thanks for the comments I
appreciate you guys uh for coming in
with the comments and everybody in chat
thanks for being here Janine's uh thanks
for the super chat again just this list
woman I appreciate you I really do every
week she's great with the super chats I
appreciate you we need agenda Jan update
listen I need agenda Gen update so I
gotta hit up Matt he's just been so busy
and we're trying to like Rebrand and do
something different because the thing is
where we were doing the podcast we he
moved because we were doing it at his
place and he actually moved so we have
to just figure it all out he changed
management companies and you know it's a
busy kid so we'll see you know what I
mean and we actually you know it didn't
get the success that we wanted it to so
we have to make sure that it makes sense
but for all you gender gen fans thanks
for the the the support that we did get
so we'll see what's happening and I'll
keep you posted on that
um
yeah so here we are uh what like now
let's see what I want to talk about this
week you know which is some stuff that I
didn't get to talk about last week so I
want to just get right into it so let's
get into some sports talk you know I
know uh if you're not into sports it is
what it is but
I want to get into some sports talk you
know what I mean so the NBA brackets
baby NBA bracket so last night the
Lakers won uh what a fantastic uh you
know what a fantastic finish so right
now if you look at the brackets in the
East it looks like it's Milwaukee's
gonna play Miami Cleveland plays New
York Philly plays Brooklyn Boston plays
Atlanta that's what it looks like it's
going to shake out to uh in in the
playoff picture right now and in the in
the west you got Denver versus Minnesota
actually I don't know if that's set yet
I think
doesn't Minnesota have to doesn't
Minnesota and Miami have to play one
more game I think so so I don't know if
it's going to be those teams or not but
the other teams had set you know
Phoenix Los Angeles what a matchup can't
wait to talk about that Sacramento
Golden State another great matchup
Memphis versus the Lakers another great
matchup
excuse me uh my voice is still a little
rocky so
you know as I look at all that stuff
um
you know the the NBA Playoffs you know
it's just I if you've been listening to
the podcast you know that I haven't
really been into the NBA as much as I
normally am this year but I have been
getting excited because the playoffs is
here man and I really I really love the
the playoffs and I love these intriguing
matchups so a lot of stuff a lot of
story lines in this year's playoffs
because one is wide open you have some
great teams in the East Milwaukee Boston
they seem to be the cream of the crop
and then right underneath that you got
uh the Philly they have the best records
in the league over the West
um and so you know what are these teams
gonna do so it's like so now that
Milwaukee's at full strength and they
got Middleton back which they didn't
have last year can Milwaukee do it again
and then it would really legitimize
their first championship right
so you have that you have Milwaukee and
then you have Cleveland I like Cleveland
because of like all the chain when they
got Donovan Mitchell and they were
already good last year and
Ken Donovan Mitchell solidify himself as
like a real bona fide star in the league
by really propelling them into like a
championship contention so we'll see New
York you know do you getting Brunson
from Dallas that guy is balling it's
changed their fate now look at them now
they're the fifth seed they didn't even
have to play to play in so like the
Knicks are relevant which makes the when
New York and La teams are relevant it's
really great for the NBA basketball so I
love that and then you got Boston but I
don't know about Boston since you know
they had this new coach uh but this guy
you know he was interim you know
everything that happened with email doku
last year with you know sleeping with
the vice president's uh wife you know
whatever the nonsense that he did you
know what I mean I mean that that was
just dumb he shouldn't have done that uh
and so now
you know so now he's uh you know he's
not coaching anymore so anyway when he
was going for the job him and this guy
the other the current Boston Coach they
were up for the job at the same time and
this email Dooku won out so now they got
this second choice is now their head
coach but we don't know how he's going
to do in the playoffs Boston made the
championship last year but can this guy
make in-game adjustments through a
series adjustments can he can he really
coach a team to the championship we'll
see but you know you got Boston
Milwaukee as favorites to go to the
championship you know so the East is
pretty strong man I think the and then
Philly you got like who's um what's his
name Joel embiid is probably going to be
the MVP he's Ballin leading the league
and scoring can James Harden get that
monkey off his back like what a good
storyline no he's always considered a
choke artist in the playoffs can this be
the year that he's not a choke artist
that he's like efficient throughout the
playoffs and him and MB can take them to
the championship like that would be a
great story Boston would be a great
story because you know then finally
winning it Milwaukee is a great story
it's a great great story like um uh
what's his name
um you know the star of Milwaukee why am
I why am I forgetting his name all of a
sudden like how to say his name uh uh uh
what what do you guys know who I'm
talking about
the star of Milwaukee man so he's like
you know it would make him it would push
him into like now two championships you
know he would he would be up there with
the greats you know what I mean Auntie
de Campo yeah yeah just got a weird name
Giannis okay so he's like you know so
that's a great story so those to me are
the teams that have like a legit like
you know great storyline you know and
then okay then you go over to the West
right you go to the West so the Lakers
won last night not in a great fashion I
feel like they should have stomped that
team but they didn't but you know you
got the Lakers they just put this team
together the Lakers got the best record
in the league since the uh trade
deadline so they are really this this
team that they put together looks great
they had their their top five defense in
in the league since the trade
so you know and you got LeBron James you
got Anthony Davis who is looks like he's
healthy and he's not gonna freaking you
know he's not he's not gonna get hurt
let's hope he doesn't get hurt you know
what I mean
so you know you got that uh and then
again when you have a little LeBron
James who's like 38 years old but still
balling at a high level it's like super
great I'm gonna give back to the Bronx
that's something to say about him so
that's a great series verse Memphis who
is the number one or two defense in the
league but they don't play well when
they're going fast uh when they're when
I'm saying I'm sorry when the game is
slowed down so this is a really
intriguing matchup can the Lakers beat
the Grizzlies or you know if the Lakers
beat the Grizzlies then we're talking
about the Lakers really have a legit
shot but they got to get past the grill
Grizzlies you know so we'll see what's
going on with that but that is great
John Morant uh all the smack talk that
the Memphis players you know that that
Brooks kid he talks a lot of smack you
know you got LeBron A.D like
what a great matchup
Sacramento golden state the no defense
no defense at all being played on on
that in that series but you got listen
defending champs Dynasty team they got
all the experience Sacramento this like
upstart team Mike Brown looking to be
coach of the year
you know in Sacramento he's got these
young one of the youngest teams in the
league they're they're the number three
seed out of nowhere they have been to
the playoffs in 16 years you know I
don't know if they're ready I don't know
if they're ready but it will be a great
matchup because Golden State they have
the worst uh uh road record in the
league they have this sort of turmoil
what's his name Wiggins is back but you
know he hasn't been playing all season
really so you can't just jump back in
and be the same as you were so they got
a lot of question marks a lot of
question marks with golden state so
we'll see
one of my favorite matchups Phoenix Los
Angeles Paul George is out but you still
got the Clippers got a deep deep team
they got they got scores coming off the
bench Defenders coming off the Bench
Phoenix depleted their bench to get
Kevin Durant so Kevin Durant and Devin
Booker have to play at a high level
every single game for them to win and
you got Kawhi you got you know what
story lines man this is what I love
about this game here's all the story
lines Chris Paul used to be a Clipper
all right so you got that storyline
Kawhi Leonard when he was with Toronto
wins the championship but there's a lot
of talk that if KD was playing they
would have won so you got that now
they're playing each other again and
both of them are relatively healthy they
actually the same kind of player they
both get injured all the time so we'll
see who survives so this is going to be
the modeling mono like who's better
right and then you got
then you got the KD Russell Westbrook
remember that stuff from back in the day
they kind of have this contentious
relationship so this is a great series I
personally think that the Clippers can
win
all the money's on Phoenix everybody's
oh Phoenix KD they should get to they're
the favorites I think the Clippers can
win this series actually I think the
Clippers like I said they're deep they
play good defense they're well coached
you know and let's remember the last
time we saw Phoenix in the champ in the
in the playoffs they got molly whopped
by Dallas by 30 in the first half so
it's like
uh I know that Phoenix has a great
record but the playoffs are different
you know they have a great record with
KD in the game but I just I'm pulling
from a Clippers I'm a Clippers fan so
I'm biased about this but I would love
to see the Clippers win this because
then it just like poo-poos and puts to
bed all this KD talk you know like first
of all in my opinion Kevin Durant is
never going to be the same okay
he plays at too high a level and his
body keeps failing him he will never
play 82 games again you heard it here
never he's 35 years old he's got two or
three
decent years left I think and he'll
never play 82 games he will always get
hurt this dude sprained his ankle in the
layup lines it's just he plays at such
an aggressive high level your body can't
do that him and LeBron James are never
going to play 82 games again LeBron 38
you'll be 39 like he's gonna have to
tone it down he's not going to be able
to do the things he's been doing because
I don't care how much money you spend on
your body father time is like yo bro you
got old knees stop it just happens like
that so I just think that this is like
to me it feels like Kevin Durant's like
best shot to lead a team be the best
player be the missing piece of a team
and take them to the championship this
is the year because I don't think he's
going to be able to do it moving forward
so this is like a big big deal and then
for the Clippers it's like Kawaii Paul
George y'all are always heard we had all
these expectations in the bubble you
choked it's like this is the time when
are you gonna do it when are you gonna
show us that you great players that like
the Clippers are so disappointing being
a Clippers fan we had so many great
chances to like have a win a
championship when we had those you know
you know the um Lob City teams Blake
Griffin and I mean we have chances but
he got hurt Chris Paul got hurt every
single year somebody got hurt and we
didn't have a chance or we choked away a
game or something you know it's like
damn this is the time another storyline
for that is Chris Paul Chris Paul's also
37 38 years old
considered one of the greatest point
guards of all time is it can he win a
championship to Lucid legitimize his
greatness so I love that series that
Series has a lot the series I don't care
about at all Denver Minnesota whoever
they're going to end up playing Denver
and whoever ends up playing Denver's got
the number one seed but there isn't I
don't think anybody outside of Denver
believes in Denver so we'll see what
happens
we'll see what happens with that so a
lot of stuff you know one of the things
I want to say about you know is the with
the Lakers and LeBron James you know
there's always this talk about who's the
best who's number one is it Jordan is it
LeBron that's the only two that you know
it's to me it's the only two that really
have a case for it you know Michael
Jordan is is already considered the
greatest player of all time and if
you're if you're an old head if you're
80s 90s kid you love Michael Jordan you
know and uh just I'm not trying to be
biased I I'm a big Jordan fan I got
Jordan posters everywhere I'm a huge
Michael Jordan fan I live through that
era so I love it uh but I think Michael
Jordan is the single greatest Talent
we've ever seen Michael Jordan in his
prime there was no one better no one's
better than Jordan in his prime okay but
when you're talking about careers like
greatest of all time careers LeBron's
had the best career of any professional
athlete like you know like
um
basketball player let's say you know I
think I think Tom Brady probably has the
best career of a professional but who
even knows you're talking about Messi uh
what's his name uh Cristiano Ronaldo who
knows who's had the best professional
sports career it's a short list of
people and LeBron's on that list I mean
you're talking about coming in the
league at 17 18 years old uh living up
to the expectations playing 19 20 years
and going to the championship 10 times
so half of his playing career he was in
the championship finishing second is not
bad people if it were the Olympics and I
told you a player had
four gold medals and six silver medals
in 10 appearances
that's phenomenal by any metric okay
just that's a phenomenal stat man so
regardless
LeBron to me already has a case so he
already has a case there are people out
there that believe he's the greatest
player ever you have a case scoring
champ he will beat Jordan in all
statistical categories he's playing at a
high level greater than Jordan did at a
later stage in his life this guy's a top
five basketball player at 38 years old
says a lot about the league in my
opinion but also him the dude takes care
of his body spends a lot of money a
million dollars a year or something like
that they say so the dude's got a case
right but here's what I'm gonna say
right now if LeBron James
takes this Lakers team
to the championship this year and wins
it's a wrap okay
that would be it that's all he needs he
would then have 11 champ uh finals
appearances five championships scoring
leader accomplishments like eight times
in a row to the championship greatest 38
year old ever you know I mean there's so
many statistics and things that he would
have a strong case like it would be hard
to argue that he's not the greatest
player of all time you know what I mean
it's just it's it's like but
that's a long shot right and that's why
it would be so great
to take a team that started two and ten
two and twelve finished the season with
a winning record uh you know
it just would be it would be a
phenomenal accomplishment for him to
lead this particular team to the
championship
you know so who knows that's just my
opinion my my humble opinion here on
riffing with Griffin so you know it's
great you know um
shout out also to another I didn't
really talk too much about Philly I like
Philly so like who's my team did I who's
my favorite teams to right now I like
Philadelphia because I really like I
like Joe and Joelle on Beats story and I
like him as a player and you know I
always relate to big men you know
because I went to a small high school so
I played center at six three so I'm fond
of the the the post play in that so I'd
love to see Joan embiid win a
championship and James Harden like
really be like hey I got this monkey off
my back I'm not a joke artist so I like
and I want to see my clippers so I would
love to see Clippers Philly in the
championship that would be crazy
that would be crazy but at the same time
I would love to see LeBron James win a
championship too at this late stage I
just LeBron I just I love LeBron James I
love how he plays I love the stories
around him I love this like magnet
magnetism he has about he's that stuff
he's that star man quintessential NBA
star iron
that would be a great story but other
than that I don't I don't really I'm not
fond of anyone else winning like if
Milwaukee wins it's like okay that's
great good for you onto the compo you
know what I mean you're now you're one
of the greats he he would he would jump
up into the top 10 greatest players of
all time in my opinion you know so that
would be you know but it's like do I
care no Celtics ah whatever not really a
Celtics fan because I'm from La so it's
always LA versus uh you know what I mean
so I wouldn't really that that wouldn't
really do anything for me you know what
I mean so I'm not really I'm I I
wouldn't really care so we'll see what
happens with that you know so I don't
like I'm saying the things I care about
the most I'd love to see I'd love to see
you the teams I care about the most
Philly
um
La both La teams Philly and both La
teams you know
but at the same time I would love to see
like
it you know it'd be great to see
I don't even know man there's so many
there would be so many great matchups in
the in the finals man like Milwaukee
Phoenix that would be a great finals
because
these you're talking about two people
that have been considered the best
players in the league Kevin Durant and
Giannis out of takumpo like those two
guys going head to head and saying and
one of them being like no I'm better
than you because Milwaukee already did
that when they were when they played you
know Milwaukee already beat him you know
what I mean so but then there was always
this thing of like Kyrie Irving Was
Heard and Kevin Durant's big toe you
know it's all that stuff so it's like
let's put that to bed so I love
I love the parody and competition that
that that the playoffs seem to have this
year so anyways that's how I feel about
the uh NBA playoffs for all the sports
talk so thanks for sticking through all
the sports talk guys I appreciate you
um I want to talk about you know so
let's do this my new segment I have
which is uh this uh segment I like to
call like you know
Instagram segment so you know you know
what's great is I I my algorithm on
Instagram now is just a lot of funny
marriage videos so these so these are a
few of my favorite like favorite so I've
been looking at dog videos and marriage
videos and when you look at these
marriage videos on Instagram you realize
you're not alone that the things that
happen to me in my relationship with
Rachel this kind of stuff happens to
everyone and I just think that this is
the good parts of the internet right now
it's the good parts you know so that's
something that I really enjoy so this is
like one of the funny videos I I have
I think this is hilarious please don't
say it don't say it don't say it don't
you dare say it don't say it don't say
it don't say it please please don't say
it don't say it
is that your other girlfriend don't say
it don't say it don't say it don't see
it this is so this is so Rachel
[Laughter]
this is so much like when I'm on the if
I if she sees me on my phone you know
what I mean this is exactly how she is
you know so it's just it's just like you
know what it's funny because like you
don't feel alone you know when you're
like watching you know you know what I
mean like when you're watching like
other
um
uh uh other like
other people's like relationship stuff
you know it's it's actually kind of cute
to realize that you know what we're not
alone in this world man we are not alone
you know so I just think this is just
one of the one of the funny marriage
videos I saw this this uh this week that
I was like how many [__] let me share
with the rear from with let me share
with the riffen with Griffin Community
you know let me change this a little bit
so another one was let's see
here's another one I think is just so
hilarious this is so me
well I don't want to play the music you
can't play the music but this is what
Rachel does she'll stand at my door and
be looking at me
and then I you get up to go talk to her
nope
shut the dough
[Laughter]
she that this is what they do man they
will stand right at the door just like
when the engine don't say they want
something they don't say they need
anything they just stare at you and then
you can get up to go give them a nope no
attention for you I'm out
I want a dog so bad you know but
Rachel's always like who's gonna take
care of the dog
the dog care the dog who's gonna clean
up
you know that's how she that that's how
she'll when she talks about a dog to me
so I don't know I mean I want a dog but
it's like I totally get that we can't
get a dog right now because she's like
you know because I travel so much but I
love good dog videos and this is one of
my favorites right here
when dogs see themselves in the mirror
foreign
[Laughter]
this dog is looking at for those people
listening on the audio this dog is
looking at himself in the mirror and
just freaking going in
I want to get a dog I don't know we
might get a dog you know we're trying to
get a dog we're trying to also have a
baby so it is what it is uh you can't
really see the this story because it's
not a video but it says NASA has
discovered a black hole moving so fast
it could travel from Earth to the Moon
in 14 minutes
I thought that I thought that was an
interesting story
I thought that was an interesting story
just because it's like you know we watch
so many movies about meteorites and
stuff like that and I was thinking like
what's really going on out there like
are we ever like if we were ever
seriously in danger of because this
they're they're talking about this black
hole is traveling through space and
destroying everything in its path
it's like are we just lucky that nothing
like that is coming in our our way like
I mean imagine like what would actually
happen if like would they it's like the
movies would they release that
information if they if they uh said hey
um yeah there's like there's there's
there's a there's a black hole that's
coming towards Earth and the moon and
it's gonna destroy our our galaxy The
Milky Way is going to be wiped out by
this thing in like 30 days like what
would you do
you know like what would you do if we
knew that we only had 30 days left like
I don't know like I just I don't know if
they would even tell people to me I kind
of feel like don't tell anyone
that's my feeling of it shoot would you
want to know I guess that's the question
would you want to know
or just like right now during my podcast
uh [__] a black hole just [__] wipes
us all out we just living Our Lives
normal or would you like wanna I don't
know if I want to know I think I would
just wanna let's just be done with it
you know I don't think I'd want to like
be sitting here counting down 30 days
and then thinking of all the stupid
things we would do and all the Anarchy
that it would cause and you know all the
Uproar and you know it's like we just
let people out of prison what are we
gonna do like like what would the world
what would what would happen
I kind of feel like it would be better
just to like for those people to keep
that knowledge to themselves and just be
like well maybe they build a spaceship
and just put like you know put put put
like make a time capsule you know what I
mean like put like Art and Science and a
hard drive full of like all the beauty
of the earth and human beings and
literature and just launch it into space
and hope some alien race finds it I
don't know I don't know I just I just
thought about that and see what you guys
what you guys think of that man what you
guys think of uh of that thing but
anyways if you have some interesting
social media videos uh on Instagram or
um on Instagram really it's just mostly
Instagram because I have it set up to
look at Instagram videos you got a funny
video just send it to me in my uh inbox
on Instagram and then uh you know if
it's good I'll play it on the show if
you have some comments I'll I'll play
that on this I'll play that on the show
as well so you know I appreciate you
guys and you know be a contributing to
the Shell so we can you know we can keep
it going
uh
anyways
what's going on next here okay so I want
to talk about a couple of shows one of
the shows I want to talk about is this
show called jury duty and my boy Ben c
word is on this show this is one of the
most fascinating shows
this is one of really the most
fascinating shows I've ever seen like
you know when you talk about let's do
something new like something new uh and
they found it this is it
from the producers of the office
you know and uh my guy Jake Never Can
Say his last name right the director he
actually was the director of Mike and
Dave
so him and some creators they created
this show and this show is like I just
it's so good okay uh like this show is
about a juror a fake case so everyone on
the show is an actor except this guy the
guy in the middle there
everyone in the song Prime it's on
Amazon Prime and it's so fascinating
because this dude is like he doesn't
know and all the people on the show are
like they're doing or I'm telling you
they're doing a really great job of this
you know acting man and doing improv you
know what I mean it's really it's really
fascinating
um James Marsden
he's playing himself and oh my God he's
doing he's doing such a great job
because like you know just it's not give
you a little spoiler alert
um one of the things I love about what
James Mars Marsden is doing is like so
the guy's like sitting there with him on
uh in the jury duty you know and then
like you know the whole idea is that a
woman walks up to him and goes oh can I
take a picture and he's sitting right
next to the the real guy you know when
the guy's like oh yeah you know I
recognized you you know and then he's
like talking about the movies that he's
been in and then the guy says he goes
he goes yeah I didn't that movie wasn't
very good and so here's the fascinating
part
such a like experiment of of like acting
and reacting because that's really what
acting is it's about the reaction you
know like this guy's legit clowning this
guy legit he's legit being like yeah you
were in a terrible movie and so in
character as himself and to also
remember that there's a show going on he
can't really have like a like ask you
know shut up fool reaction that somebody
you know what I mean to keep that in
character uh he does such a great job
but it's so funny man like it's so funny
and I think that part of it when you're
watching it you're you're you're seeing
the experiment and you're really
fascinated about it you're just like
like like seeing these performances and
so it's a very much a combination so
there's like some scripted moments that
they have and then there's like when
they're interacting with this guy it's
like a very much a bunch of improv but
they know what they're trying to get you
know they're trying to lead him and he
gives them everything they could
possibly want you know they really can
to do this such a like he's such a
goofball you know like the dudes the
right amount of dumb right but also
genuine and sweet and you're pulling for
him and and then these actors are doing
such a great job around him making him
you know uh uh like sort of like
prodding him to go in a certain way and
then he gives them even more than they
even asked for so this is lot of things
I like about it but it makes me feel a
lot of things you know it's like
you know
like this guy's giving a raw natural
reaction and that's what we love we love
seeing that that's what reality
television is about that's why we like
watching like and even though it feels
sometimes like certain reality TV it's
sort of like you feel like it's scripted
you feel like their producers are
pushing in a certain way but there's
something about what we love about
rawness right but at the same time
that's what great acting is great acting
is when an actor can make you believe
that this is a real emotion and reaction
to whatever the scene is and that's an
art form that I hope that this doesn't
take away from that you know uh it's
kind of a combination of both because
there's a part of it that you love
watching this guy's real reaction to the
craziness that these actors are creating
and so we're we're very drawn to that
but at the same time I like watching
also
a person
like if this guy was a real actor
pretending to be a fake you know what
I'm saying and he was giving these
reactions that would be an incredible
artistic performance and he would get
kudos for that so it's like I hope we
don't go away from that but this is
really a really fascinating uh artistic
art experiment of combining the Two
Worlds of like scripted written
stuff with this sort of behind the
scenes Truman Show
uh thing
so you really gotta like I I highly
recommend it you know I really do and
then it's just also it's just
it's just funny like James Martin
Marsden whatever his name is he's so
funny playing himself like in this
situation like he's trying to get out of
jury duty because he's famous and he
can't and it's like all those things are
are going on and again my buddy Ben uh
he he's he's in it and he's being very
serious because and then the so so he's
given some like ground he's like this
grounded serious person while everyone
else while some craziness is going on
and that helps like you're really seeing
some great performances in this and it's
like a it's a one-of-a-kind show that
you know I it's I think it's gonna spark
a new genre of entertainment of people
doing this and trying this out and so
like I say I do highly recommend it uh
and all these people on the screen right
now they're so funny like all the things
that are happening it's just so freaking
funny man like anything you can think
about jury duty they're doing
for you know and seeing how this guy's
gonna react and his reactions are just
uh chef's kiss man
so I I do like I said once again I
highly recommend it and I give it like
10 wolves
[Music]
so check out jury duty it's called
freebie but you can see it on Amazon
Prime so you can either have freebie
which is like whatever the branch of
Amazon that is but I watch it on Prime
so if you have Prime check it out on
Prime
all right that's my jury duty
um
what do you call it a review love that
show next show I want to review in last
and we'll finish off with this is
succession man
oh man dude I don't know if you guys are
watching this show
but man this show was great this year
like this is the last season of the show
and they I mean I don't know why that
like this is an example of what I like
these are some really great actors
I don't know if you know what the show's
about if you've never seen
successionists on HBO Max but this is
about the Royal Roy family is known for
controlling the biggest media
entertainment company in the world
however their world changes when their
father steps down from the company
that's this season's
you know and so
you know it's about privilege man
you know it's about
you know super wealthy and how they act
and how they interact with each other
and like you know just the you know so
this this mean guy he you know he's he's
supposed to be Rupert Murdoch you know
what I mean like it's about it's kind of
like mocking that family you know and
you got these kids who are like dumb
they are just stupid people you know but
they have wealth and power and they're
pretending to be smarter than they
really are they don't trust each other
they don't you know you can tell they
love each other but they hate each other
and just the interactions amongst what's
going on with this family and the people
around them and the acting is just
superb this year like it really is and I
always loved the last season of a show I
love a last season of a show because
they
they you know they they gonna do they're
gonna they can do anything they can kill
anyone they can make anything happen
because they know they don't have to
clean it up in the next season and I
love that so A last season of a show
sometimes you get really great
television or sometimes they take too
big of a swing and it just doesn't work
but in this case so far I feel like it's
working great
so I do highly recommend the final
season of succession uh you know these
actors are doing great like what's some
of the actors let's get their names
let's give people some Kudos man so
Brian Cox that's the main guy you know
he's he don't you know what I mean he's
so good in this uh uh and then Macaulay
Culkin's brother Karen Culkin he you
know he's he's so he's like so genuine
and sweet in the show I don't know it's
just everybody I don't want to go
because I don't because a lot of these
actors you don't really I say their
names and you'll be like I don't know
who the hell you're talking about but
you know it's fun stuff man you know
so I don't know if you're watching so
like if you have a show out there that
you know you're you'd like you you you
really love because I'm gonna check out
some more shows that are coming out you
know I do want to check out some uh some
more shows like like I just started
watching this uh
what's oh man what is this Netflix show
there's a Netflix show right now
starring Rob Lowe uh what is the name of
this show uh let's see
um what is the name of it man it's on
right now anybody know the name of that
show that Rob blows in right now on
Netflix
um it's called oh why can't I find it on
it's not oh unstable
there's a show called unstable
um
it's so funny
I I really so I'm gonna review that one
probably next week
so make sure you guys check that out if
you haven't watched that I like unstable
I'm gonna check out beef haven't watched
that yet I still haven't seen John Wick
4 which is crazy that I haven't seen
that but I'm probably gonna go see that
this weekend because I'm out in hey guys
guess I'm out in uh Missouri this week
so make sure you come check me out in
Missouri
your boy is going to be out in Missouri
so here's some of my tour dates that's
coming up uh so make sure you come check
me out I'm gonna be in the Blue Room
comedy club in Springfield Missouri
that's starting this weekend April 13th
through the 15th so come check me out
there and then I'm not I people keep
sending me messages about this you said
you want your fans to come say this the
name right Louisville Louisville is it
Louisville or Louisville I don't know
how to say it right but Louisville
Comedy Club April 20th to the 22nd come
check me out there you can click these
links for tickets the mothership I have
to change this link I think they had the
ticket link up now I'm gonna be at the
comedy Mothership April 28th to the 30th
shout out to Joe Rogan and his new club
and then I have some more dates coming
Nashville and stand up live in
Huntsville One Night in Nashville and
then the weekend in Huntsville and then
also got Tampa coming up I'll put those
all on the website so make sure you know
you guys come come you know come check
me out in a city near you uh yeah so you
know and I gotta say if you have some
videos that you want to send me
if you have some videos that you like
and you want to send me stuff come you
know send send it to me man I will I
want to
you know I want to uh
you know look at funny fun stuff and you
know do different things here on riffin
with Griffin but guys I appreciate you
guys we're not doing a full hour today
uh you know I'm still doing the podcast
I love doing it I'm gonna try to grow
I'm trying to do more overlays we're
trying to get this we're trying to get
this stuck uh you know still jumping off
I appreciate all my loyal fans people
come see me in public they see me
probably like yo man I love your podcast
I love when you guys do that I love when
people come watch me do stand up what I
do right here isn't the same as my
stand-up what I do here isn't the same
as like check me out on the golden hour
that's a you know we got patreon on the
golden hour and we got you know the the
four free episodes that we do so check
me out there too man I'm just like uh I
got all kinds of personalities and sides
to myself but I love doing my podcast
live I just like doing it like this for
a lot of reasons one is that you don't
take a lot of editing because it's just
me doing it like this and two I just
like I like the stream of Consciousness
and just like talking about something
Raw full effect you know what I mean
so anyways y'all
you know how we do this
we got the rap recap
thank you so much for coming back
ripping with Griffin
I'm always sniffing
big ass nose
cause everybody knows and today NBA
playoffs
people about to go off
Kevin Durant do it
can he take his team through it
jury duty everybody got a big booty
Rudy Tootie go to IHOP and get that
fresh and fruity
succession
[Music]
is quick
for goodness sake
[Music]
I need a state
old man raps
let dips foot Taps let those hands clap
welcome back see you next week come back
[Music]
I might wear my hat
tap tap
[Music]
anyways thanks for watching
now the new season of war zone is about
to come out so come check me out
on air Griffin gaming on Twitch
I'll be on there shortly
thanks for watching Eric Griffin
on Griffin with Griffin
see you next week
[Music]